Let's see if we can
learn a thing or
two about Sn2 reactions.
And you're going to see a lot of
these in organic chemistry.
This sounds like a
very fancy term.
But it really just stands
for-- the S stands for
substitution.
The n stands for nucleophilic.
And then the 2, and this is
probably maybe the least
obvious part of Sn2, the 2 comes
from the fact that the
rate-determining step
in this reaction
involves both reactants.
And I'm going to show
you what we mean.
And it'll actually be probably
more clear when we compare it
to Sn1 reactions.
So let me show you
an Sn2 reaction.
Let's say we have
bromomethane.
And let me draw it in
three dimensions.
You have a hydrogen
sticking out.
Maybe the bromine is
right over there.
And then you have another
hydrogen in the back.
And then you have a hydrogen
that comes up just like that.
And here, the three dimensions
won't matter that much.
This is not a chiral carbon.
There's no handedness here.
But in the future, we'll think
about chiral carbons and what
might happen to them as they
undergo Sn2 reactions.
So I have this bromomethane
here.
And let's say we also have
some hydroxide in
solution with it.
So it's a hydroxide,
and this oxygen has
seven valence electrons.
You could imagine that the way
that you get a hydroxide is if
you start off with water,
that looks like this.
And maybe there's another water
someplace else that
looks like that.
And maybe in one step, this
water right here takes this
guy's hydrogen.
Remember, there's a partially
positive charge on the
hydrogen, partially negative
charge on the oxygen.
So maybe he gives one of his
electrons to the hydrogen,
which will end up with
a positive charge.
It'll be a hydronium cation.
And then this electron takes
back that extra electron from
the hydrogen.
And so now, he's going to have
seven valence electrons.
He's going to have this one.
That was at this end of the
bond of the one that he's
taking back.
And then that's two, three,
four, five, six, and then this
electron right there, seven.
So he's going to have one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven valence electrons.
And he's going to have
a negative charge.
It's neutral when it's water.
When he takes an extra electron,
it's going to have a
negative charge.
And you could imagine this is in
a solution with water, that
water is our solvent.
So let me put a negative
charge right here.
I can write minus 1 if I want.
And in this reaction, just so
we know what's what, this
hydroxide molecule, or this
hydroxide anion, is our
nucleophile.
It is the nucleophile
right there.
And the best way to think about
a nucleophile is it
likes other people's
nucleuses.
It likes them because nucleuses
are positive.
It has extra electrons.
In this case, it has a negative
charge, so it is
attracted to other nucleuses.
Nucleuses of atoms are positive,
so it is attracted
to electrons.
Phile, I'm not a Greek scholar,
but it means to be
attracted or to like
something, so it likes nucleuses.
And if you want to compare it
to acids or bases, you'd
classify this actually as a
Lewis base, something that
gives electrons.
But we're not going to go
into that right now.
This is a nucleophile.
It is attracted to nucleuses,
to positive things.
It wants to give
away electrons.
Now, what's going to happen is
that this is going to give an
electron to this carbon.
This carbon's going to say,
oh, I got an electron.
Let me give away an electron to
somebody who probably wants
it really badly.
And in this case, it's going
to be the bromine because
we've seen multiple times
that the bromine is very
electronegative.
It already is starting to hog
the electrons, and it would
like to take an electron
altogether.
And so let me show
you the reaction.
It's going to happen
very quickly.
Or it's actually going to happen
very quickly the way I
drew it, because it's really
a one-step reaction.
So you're going to have one of
these electrons right here
will attack the carbon.
Or I shouldn't say attack.
It sounds very aggressive.
It will be given
to the carbon.
And then the carbon says, oh,
I'm getting an electron from
this direction.
It actually has a slightly
positive charge at this end,
because the bromine is hogging
some of the electrons, so
they'll be attracted
to each other.
They're going to bump into each
other just the right way.
And then at the exact same time,
this all has to happen
kind of simultaneously.
At the exact same time, this
electron, sitting at that end
of the bond, is going to
go to the bromine.
And so what is it going to look
like when this reaction
has actually occurred?
So it's literally a
one-step reaction.
So you have your carbon.
You have the hydrogen
that is pointing up.
Now, let me color code this.
So that'll make it
interesting.
So you have this hydrogen,
that is
coming out of the screen.
And it's still just coming
straight out of the screen,
but I'm going to draw it to the
down right, because this
hydroxide's attacking
from behind.
And this bromine, which we call
the leaving group, or
actually, it's going to be a
bromide anion once it leaves,
that's going to leave
from the right.
Attack from the left, leave
from the right,
from different sides.
So then this is that hydrogen
that's sticking out.
The hydrogen in the back--
well, we know it's in the
back, so I'll just continue to
draw it in the back like that.
And now this hydroxide
is going to be
attached to the carbon.
So this carbon now gets one of
those electrons, and it is
bonded now to the oxygen.
Let me draw the oxygen.
So you have the oxygen.
Let me see the best way
that I could do this.
So you have the oxygen here
bonded to a hydrogen.
And let me draw its
valence electrons.
So it had one, two, three, four,
five, six, and then it
had a seventh electron, but
it just gave it away.
So its seventh electron is going
to bond with this one.
They were already a
pair over here.
Let me make it very clear
what the color is.
This electron right over
there is this electron.
But it was already paired with
this guy, so when he gives it
away to the carbon, it forms
this covalent bond right here.
So now you have this OH group,
this hydroxyl group, off of
the carbon now.
And now the bromine, you had a
negatively charged group here.
Now, what I've drawn so far,
everything is neutral.
So something has to be
negatively charged.
It's going to be the bromine
because that's what getting
the electron.
So now the bromine, if I wanted
to draw bromine's
valence shell, before it would
have seven electrons, so one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven.
Now that it's taking that
electron from carbon, it's
going to have eight: one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
and let me color
code it again.
So this electron right here,
when it goes to the bromine,
is going to be that electron
right there, and we're going
to have a negative charge.
And so here, in this situation,
just to make sure,
this is the nucleophile.
The bromine right here, this
is the leaving group.
And then the carbon, I guess
the thing that is reacting,
that's getting substituted,
where the bromine leaves it
and the hydroxide joins it,
that's called the substrate.
So I could draw it like this.
This is the substrate.
And the whole reason why
I did it, this was
not a chiral carbon.
But you could imagine, once we
deal with chiral carbons, when
they undergo an Sn2 reaction
like this, their chirality
will actually change.
So I'll leave you
there right now.
That'll give you something to
think about, Sn2 reactions.
And then in the next video,
we'll think a
little bit about Sn1.
Oh, and before I leave you, I
left you hanging on the 2.
I said this is called
substitution.
You saw that the bromine was
substituted by the hydroxide.
It's nucleophilic.
It involved this hydroxide,
which likes nucleuses.
And then I said the
rate-determining step involves
both reactants.
And here, it might not be
completely clear, but the
rate-determining step
was actually what's
going on right here.
And if I were to draw an
intermediate, you could
actually draw an intermediate
step here.
Let me copy and paste
this down here.
So you could actually draw an
intermediate step, so let me
copy the other one.
Let me copy this.
Copy and paste.
This all happens over one step,
but if we wanted to show
what happens in between, for a
small amount of time, you have
this transition state, where the
carbon is going to have a
partial bond, so it has
this hydrogen in blue.
Let me draw this hydrogen
in blue sticking out.
And it has another hydrogen
behind it.
I'll draw it like it's
right behind it.
And then for some small fraction
of time, it is bonded
to both the bromine-- so I'll
draw it with a dotted line.
It is bonded to both the
bromine, which now will have a
partial negative charge because
it's starting to get
an electron, and it's also
bonded to the hydroxide, which
also has a partial
negative charge.
You can imagine this negative
charge is now getting split
between the two.
This is a transition state.
And the notation for a
transition state, you put
brackets around it, or
parentheses, in some cultures,
they call them, and you write
this little symbol up here.
This tells us this is
a transition state.
This is not one of the
semi-stable intermediates.
This is something that
we're going through.
This is an Sn2 reaction because
this transition state
is actually what determines
the rate of the reaction.
This requires the highest energy
state of this reaction.
This is what's going to-- well,
I said it already--
determine its rate.
And in this transition state,
this rate-determining step,
you have all of the reactants.
You have your hydroxide right
there, and you also have your
bromomethane that we
started with, so it
has two of the reactants.
That's why it's called
an Sn2 reaction.